hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong the podcast
that is hosted by me Mark Ellis hello
welcome back and to
Jacqueline Coley is here she's back akin
to the villain that we're talking about
in this horror franchise you just can't
get rid of her she takes some vacations
she takes some work trips she's back
Jacqueline you've been all over the
globe you've been Jet Set and you've
been hobnobbing you've been watching
movies drinking champagne how is thee
I'm good I'm glad to be back you guys
were admirable I loved the Topher Grace
episode I I will say all of them were
great but having that moment having you
have your thing and also I might add
because I Mark knows that like that was
my first crush was Tofer Grace yeah yes
you picked the right one yeah that was
my first crush some ladies picked me
they picked the wrong one
serongo well I'm glad we I'm glad we did
and look I am back and it's good that
we're doing it on this one because I
literally think like Freddy's back
payback like this is just like it's like
a moment of return don't you think I
think that you can never quite Shake
Freddy Krueger I don't care how one of
The Nightmare on Elm Street movies ends
if you're like oh finally we can go back
to sleep it's like Kenya for how long I
would take Metallica's advice and sleep
with one eye open because you never know
with Freddy Krueger Jacqueline and I
were back talking together it's like our
conversation fits like an old glove like
somebody else relies on that has a lot
of razor blades on it but you you have a
very different relationship with scary
movies in general than I do so I want to
get into that once we once we we
actually start the movie talk portion
like where we're all coming from
psychologically into these horror movies
but for right now there is uh there's an
editorial shout out I want to give
because we're here in the midst of
spooky season it's Halloween season it's
uh dentists love this time of year and
there's a great article on
rottentomatoes.com that's all the
nightmare on the street movies ranked
and so you can see the ranking according
to Tomato Meter which our good friend
Tim Ryan is about to reveal to us but
it's just a fun sort of to walk for me
anyway down memory lane in my childhood
seeing
um and and it's a moment of Pride for me
Jacqueline because you know the movies
in the nightmare Elm Street Canon that
really had an effect on me that I still
have an affinity for and I think they're
very well represented is what I'll say I
think I did I did good with my opinions
and I feel validated by the Tomato Meter
I I think you're right on that and also
can I just say like whenever I think of
you Mark I very much think of you as a
guy that went away to like the very
idyllic no offense waspy summer camps
like like I know you probably weren't
but I'm like I just feel like you had an
Indian summer somewhere in your past I
think I was like one of the other kids
at that camp that they went to in Adams
Family Values is that what you're
accusing me of okay this is this is what
happens
well we haven't seen seen each other in
a while but I actually did go to a
summer camp that was right next door to
a nuclear power plant and I was watching
The Three Mile Island documentary on
Netflix last night it was it wasn't a
Three Mile Island one but uh that's
where I went so it was pretty much like
I was in The Simpsons uh you know
Nightmare on Elm Street we love Freddy
Krueger you know he's the one murdering
teenagers I don't know who to root for a
guy from Hell who's evil or teenagers
it's a tough call there and it just sort
of repeats and then you have these these
Rises and these Falls uh you know you
get sequelitis sometimes with The
Nightmare on Elm Street but then you get
something holy original like Wes
Craven's New Nightmare get to see Freddy
and Jason tussle you get to see a remake
so we want to get into our opinions here
on a Nightmare on Elm Street and we're
gonna do that today with a very special
guest who is well versed in all things
horror he doesn't just watch the horror
movies he makes them he has directed a
few brilliant short films with his
company Amateur hour films he is the
host of the wangers podcast alongside
our producer Brian Perez and Cody Hall
and occasionally he puts me through my
Paces as a producer at Rotten Tomatoes
it is the owner of Draco the Wonder Dog
Christian ruval Kaaba making his first
guest appearance here on Rotten Tomatoes
is wrong good day sir hello thank you
guys so much for having me this is so
much fun this is uh my my favorite time
of the year it's spooky month and what
better way to celebrate that than
talking my favorite horror franchise of
all time are you a costume guy
no no it's my favorite time but I never
dress up never dude now that I now that
I have a dog and now I'm gonna have to
dress up we're dressing him up so I have
to be part of it this is a recent dog
Edition yeah okay so and you named him
Draco yeah he when we got him from the
shelter my girlfriend's a huge Harry
Potter fan and his full name already was
Draco Malfoy and she was like he's
perfect
so so
he says he's our little Draco mouth he
doesn't he's more of a Hufflepuff really
I mean that's like kind of naming your
kid Joffrey I'm like yeah yeah yeah
I think I see I I'll defend Christian
just with the Joffrey example because I
feel like Draco was the name of that kid
that evil kid and then Joffrey came
along and it's like now you can name
your kid Draco again you just can't name
him Joffrey anymore yeah Fair like
there's the worst kid because remember
back in our day it was like the good son
it was Macaulay Culkin and the good son
that was like the crazy kid you didn't
want to be myself with Christian River
Caba as a producer and engineer might be
recording a versus episode of the career
of Elijah Wood versus not Macaulay
Culkin but Elijah Wood gets a lot of
mention in the good son in the vid so
there's a lot of stuff going on here at
Rotten Tomatoes we're very excited about
all of it Christian rubalcaba is on
board he did a deep dive into nightmare
in Elm Street I've been doing a deep
dive my entire life and Jacqueline has
her highlights and lowlights as well so
before we get into movie talking there's
a lot to discuss here with everybody's
favorite stand-up comics slash evil
villain child murder let's go to Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong oh own review cure
rate it really does the reviews for
really everybody that submits their
reviews it's Tim Ryan he's the guy that
sort of puts it all together gets the uh
the percentage along with our great team
at Rotten Tomatoes so Tim Ryan is going
to tell us what the critics were saying
about the releases of nightmare and Alma
Street the highlights he's going to run
us down the list from Tomato Meter top
to bottom Tim Ryan it's your two minutes
take it away
[Music]
like any horror franchise The Nightmare
on Elm Street films have had their ups
and downs that said the Freddy Krueger
Saga has a higher share of undeniable
winners than many of its ilk and critics
and audiences are generally in agreement
about each entry in the series let's
break it down a Nightmare on Elm Street
from 1984 is certified fresh at 95 on
the Tomato Meter and it has an 84
audience score
and named Mary Elm Street 2 Freddy's
Revenge from 1985 is rotten at 40 and it
has a 33 audience score A Nightmare on
Elm Street 3 Dream Warriors from 1987 is
fresh at 72 percent and it has a 68
audience score A Nightmare on Elm Street
4 the dream master from 1988 is rotten
at 53 and has a 43 audience score A
Nightmare on Elm Street 5 the dream
child from 1989 is rotten at 28 and it
has a 31 audience score the in
retrospect mistitled Freddy's Dead the
Final Nightmare from 1991 is rotten at
23 and has a 32 audience score Wes
Craven's New Nightmare from 1994 is
certified fresh at 79 and it has a 66
audience score the Friday the 13th
crossover Freddy vs Jason from 2003 is
rotten at 42 and has a 50 audience score
and finally the 2010 reboot a Nightmare
on Elm Street is rotten at 14 and has a
43 percent audience score so what do the
critics have to say in a fresh review
for the 1984 Nightmare on Elm Street
variety called it a highly imaginative
horror film that provides the requisite
shocks to keep fans of the genre happy
however in a rotten review for the 2010
Nightmare on Elm Street Nicholas allowed
the San Francisco Chronicle wrote people
have dreams and either get their guts
ripped out or don't get their guts
ripped out and then after 90 or so
minutes are used up the movie finds some
weak pretext for ending so that's the
Nightmare on Elm Street franchise and
here's a weird bit of trivia almost 28
years prior to this recording on October
14 1994 you could head down to the
theater to watch the certified Fresh Wes
Craven's New Nightmare
or among the other certified fresh
opening releases you could take your
pick between Pulp Fiction the Shawshank
Redemption hoop dreams or the Indie
romantic comedy I like it like that oh
and Edward and quiz show hit theaters
the week before and clerks would be
released the week after so pretty good
stretch for movies back to you folks all
right pretty good little pocket of uh
movie going lore there with I don't know
what you take if you're going to the
movies and I'm sure a lot of folks would
say Pulp Fiction I would probably end up
walking into Wes Craven's New Nightmare
Christian if those are your options that
you just heard in 1994 when you were
still a zygote where are you walking
into what's the theater I mean Mark you
know I'm a huge basketball guy I'm going
hoop dreams no great documentary that is
the Oscars it is a great documentary but
I'm their nightmare for sure and then I
hear the buzz about Pulp Fiction I'll go
in and check that out afterwards I
believe one of those people buzzing
about Pulp Fiction is going to be
Jacqueline I think this is where we part
ways right yes yes yes anyway that's
what maybe we'll talk about that on a
future episode who knows what's going to
happen here but for right now let's hit
the music for movie talk
[Music]
ah finally it's just like I know it
freaks people out but I think Christian
is the same way it just you start
talking about a franchise like this that
is so steeped in horror war and it's
just this mythologically great villain
if not all the movies living up to that
it's just like a warm blanket for for us
Jacqueline but you seem to have a
different outlook on scary movies what
is your take on scary movies what was it
when you were a kid what ingratiated you
do to it what steered you away from it
now we're here as adults and you feel
how I hate scary movies or I did I don't
I love them now but when I was like
younger what it was is the first thing I
watched that was scary was Tales from
the Crypt and the Twilight Zone and I
learned very quickly with horror certain
scary things I was cool with and certain
scary things would mean my mother was in
my room at four or five times in the
night was screaming Jags and so horror
wasn't that I didn't enjoy it it was
just unsafe I have since aged and
matured and the night mirrors don't like
come to me but literally I remember I
was like 16 and went on a date and you
know how boys were back in the day take
her to the scary movie dog like yeah
yeah like let me tell you how this went
down uh he took me to the scary movie
she was traumatized and never spoke to
him again
that was a movie
it was The Grudge and it wasn't even
that scary but I was done I was done
with him I told you I didn't want to see
a scary movie I told you I didn't like
scary movies and then you took me to a
scary movie I had nightmares so I called
him the next morning and broke up with
him no lie Terry if you're listening to
this I stand by it poor Terry Terry you
don't here's the problem with taking
someone to a scary movie they're
romantically interested in you don't
take them to a scary movie where a lot
of the stuff happens in the bedroom
because then if you happen to get lucky
later on maybe dude Jacqueline and Terry
probably too young but you get into the
bedroom then you're just thinking about
that and that scene which is why
Nightmare on Elm Street great horror
movies I don't know that they're
necessarily date night horror Fair
um Christian your gateway into horror
movies in general let's back up a step
was what and did you take to it
immediately did you get freaked out what
was the play well I'm I'm in a similar
boat with Jacqueline because I too was a
it was a big scaredy cat like I I just
hated everything scary even even to like
like scenes from like Jurassic Park
everything was terrifying to me and uh
it was actually The Nightmare on Elm
Street franchise that really got me into
horror
um uh the the First the movie that
actually got me into it was uh Freddy's
Revenge nightmare Elm Street part two
because I was at a sleepover with
friends and their mom his mom uh got a
couple uh VHS from Blockbuster you guys
remember those uh and she said I got
Nightmare on Elm Street all the kids
were all excited and I was like yeah
cool and I didn't want to be that one
guy that was like no I don't want to
watch that I'd rather watch Willy Wonka
um yeah I can't be afraidy cat in that
situation can't no even that movie has
some scary stuff in it but she she pops
it in and it turns out to be Freddy's
Freddy's Revenge nightmare announcing
part two and if anybody knows anything
about that movie it's it's a little
silly and there's actually some subtext
to it that I would learn later about it
in life and but but the movie like kind
of taught me that horror movies don't
have to be always that scary it's not
always it doesn't always have to be you
know the X Exorcist or The Blair Witch
Project that they can be kind of fun and
silly and um that really kind of like
okay that kind of opened it up and then
over the years I just started liking the
more twisted and messed up stuff you
know it's it is a gateway it is walking
through that gate and so it's literal in
the sense of a nightmare in Elm Street
because a lot of times when a teenager
has fallen asleep even though they're
trying to stay awake and they're going
to tussle with Freddy they find
themselves standing in front of a house
with a creepy gate and there's like a
tricycle and it's like oh don't walk
into the house they always walk into the
house we know what's going to happen
after that don't go to the boiler room
so you are making great points here
Jacqueline you really should do more
podcasting here's the thing because like
Jacqueline said that she loved watching
Tales from the Crypt as a kid and the
The Genius of Tales from the Crypt and
the thing that made it palatable to me
is that the Crypt Keeper himself was
horrendous looking scary but funny could
could deliver a joke could have a funny
setup and a nice payoff same thing with
Freddie a Krueger and so whereas The
Exorcist and I'll even give you some
credit for The Grudge jackly because
there's not a lot of levity in those
movies there's not a lot of joking
around Freddy himself particularly as
the movies continue to make more sequels
Freddie got funnier and funnier and he
was almost like you're rooting for
Freddy oh but let me give it to you camp
he is the original drag queen ladies and
gentlemen boys and girls let me tell you
I can't wait till we get into deeper
into it but no Freddy is drag Freddy is
Camp Freddy is heightened costumery and
so yeah like every ounce of that the
more they leaned into it and Robert is
sis
he is sassier than a gay man on RuPaul's
Drag Race I love it
um we have a great video and I really
hope Brian you pull it up where Jordan
peel talks about Freddy and he says like
how much he loves that movie and he's
just like dinner sir like just that
level of like Gore and Camp leprechaun
does that really well too when we got to
the 80s in the Supernatural killers and
like Freddy's out there killing you know
people and and
um you know doing like a bit like
he's holding his own
dinners served you know when you're
doing the the bit he became like a
surrogate for the audience in this weird
way and I feel like he he tapped in to
some suppressed aggression something
that needed to get out and it became
this this different kind of interactive
experience where you start cheering and
rooting for the the Killer and the um
the the the teenagers uh you know become
less and less likable in their portrayal
if we look at the movies though I mean
at some point the movie has to hold up
like I think that's the thing that sunk
the leprechaun is that we love him he's
cute he's funny but the movie's not
really that good the first The Nightmare
on Elm Street way back in 1984 I think
has earned its place as the number one
movie on this list but Christian you're
our esteemed guest today I'll turn it
over to you when you hear that rundown
that Tim Ryan gave us from top to bottom
it's on rottentomatoes.com right now
what is is your take is it accurate do
you have a lot of beef there no I mean I
think I think maybe some of the movies
being rotten is a little too harsh I
mean I I also have a personal just like
love for these movies I I can recognize
that they're not like of the best
quality especially when you know a lot
of the behind the scenes in the
production of a lot of these films where
they just kind of rushed it and were
writing as they were making them but
like I think the top three being the the
original nightmare Wes Craven's New
Nightmare and Dream Warriors is is
totally perfect and accurate
um I would give a little bit more room
for Freddy vs Jason because that is like
the most fun uh movie I think I've ever
seen
um and then also Freddy's Freddy's
Revenge that one too because it has just
a soft spot in my heart I think um
there's some there's some really good
stuff in that one again there's a
there's a little bit of uh behind the
scenes for that movie which if you
wanted a great companion piece to
Freddy's revenge is actually a a
documentary called scream Queen My
Nightmare on Elm Street it is wonderful
uh Mark Patton who stars in that movie
went through so much stuff in that movie
and now he's kind of you know
taken what he was referred to as back
then as as like the first like male
scream Queen
um and he's just taking it to heart and
actually like owning it now and for the
longest time he didn't
um so there's a lot of uh history with
that in the rest of the franchise but I
think the list overall is is pretty
solid yeah Jaclyn I would look at a
nightmare in Elm Street from 1984 the
the original one with the same eyes that
I would even do John Carpenter's 1978
Halloween simply because those were made
on shoestring budgets Halloween cost
under 400 Grand to make and obviously
turned a huge profit I never on Elm
Street cost around a million dollars to
make which wasn't a lot of money even
back then and it ended up grossing 57
million dollars it was a hit it felt
original it's Wes Craven behind the
camera so when you see that movie you
see the potential not just for this
movie to be a recurring scary classic
around this time of year but you really
do see a franchise being launched yeah I
mean that's the kicker with this too and
I think what's interesting with horror
and one of the reasons why I like came
around on horror is with franchises when
they're done well and even if there's
like bad entries or high up entries so
long as they all hold the same I think
tone and theme you can like fall in love
with it the way that Christian does and
so I think look is a lot of them you
know want to throw it out of the boat
sure but I also think there's later
entries and I would absolutely agree on
Freddy versus Jason where even though
they stayed within the tone of Nightmare
Before Elm Street they still pushed it
in a way and it's like they built a
framework and an archetype and the
directors that I think are the best of
the ones that that push those but didn't
like abandon them the later entries
abandon them yeah Freddy versus Jason is
it's 42 rotten and it's it's audience
score is 50 and if we just want to dive
into that movie I will say that I can
agree with the audience I cannot get
fresh on that movie I was so excited for
that and I get that they're trying to
lean into the tone of the 80s but
they're still trying to modernize it for
2003 I think is when it's released and
yeah it's these two iconic villains
going back and forth and I just felt so
like this should be epic and it never
felt like that to me it it felt like
just a slowly the air coming out of a
pool float until the end when there's
this battle and then they're just
setting us up for this ridiculous sequel
with Jason walking out of the water
after we think that he's killed Freddy
and decapitated him he's holding
Freddy's head and the last thing you see
is Freddie wank I want a definitive
winner or I want more movies like you
got to give me one of the other you
can't just have that be the last thing
that we see sorry that that alone
deserves a rotten rating for me yeah no
I I I get it especially because the
movie has such a great concept behind it
the fact that people aren't afraid of
Freddy anymore so he uses Jason to
install that fear so he can come back I
think the only flaw to that is that the
movie ends up being more of a Friday the
13th movie than it but then it's a
nightmare movie yeah the sequences that
we have with Freddy are are few and
they're great because they actually he
actually pulls
um he actually pulls Jason into his
dream and you throw him around like a
pinball it's great that's a cool scene
it's really really cool but you don't
even get a lot of Freddy kills I think
he only kills like one person in the
entire movie and it's it's it's mostly a
Jason movie so there's a lot of stuff
that they could have like done and that
movie was in development hell for the
longest time uh fun fact did you know
what one of the uh like proposed endings
would have been for that movie No it's
it's got to be better than the wink give
it to me one of the one of the pitches I
think I don't think I think maybe
they're storyboard for it but uh as the
two are fighting each other
um then all of a sudden like they get
like pulled into hell and Pinhead pulls
them apart and tells them to cut it out
and he says stop it you two need to stop
doing this and they introduce Pinhead
into it and there's also com books I
think where they do more Freddy vs Jason
ash from Evil Dead gets involved as well
so there's a lot of fanfic out there
people still love Hellraisers
can I just say this because I feel like
we're gonna get to this episode and
we're not gonna be able to really dive
deep into the encyclopedic knowledge of
what Christian has inside his brain so
can I just take
quality and have you I'm not even
kidding like I'm dead ass on this give
me like the top three like shocking
Christian things that you've got on the
night mail from my own Street franchise
because I guarantee you they're they're
better than anything we would be able to
say for the rest of this episode legit
like just give me like three or like
just give me one of your favorite
mind-blowing Nightmare on Elm Street
fact it's just one green a good one like
like your favorite one my favorite one
um Christian think on this for a minute
because I got a good one for Jaclyn too
because it's one that I learned in
prepping for this episode is that around
the year 2000 they were because again
this is coming off of the heat the
critical and fan heat from uh Wes
Craven's New Nightmare which was sort of
a Resurgence because it was so meta and
it was like looking into Freddy and then
Freddy looking deeper into Freddy and
Robert England and Heather langenkamper
back and it's it's a really cool Journey
Inside the Mind of Wes Craven and then
in 2000 there were plans to develop a
prequel to The First Nightmare on Elm
Street that was going to be set in hell
at least partially and so you get to
sort of see that and you might get to
see like the parents getting together
and killing Freddie
um in real life but it was scrapped and
and a big reason why it was scrapped is
because the Adam Sandler movie Little
Nicky which was also set primarily in
hell did not do well at the box office
it was the first big big bomb for Adam
Sandler it was the first big bomb for
Adam Sandler and so then nuan is like ah
we can't do movies based in hell it's
not going to work and so we didn't get
the prequel and I think that would have
been a cool way to take it
um but yeah so that's my little factoid
for the day Christian what's your what's
your mic drop moment well I will say
I'll say any facts that I know it's all
because of it and maybe this could be
one of them uh is because there is a
great like six hour documentary on The
Nightmare on Elm Street series called
never sleep again it's a nightmare
Legacy or something like that it is
awesome because it does take you through
all the behind the scenes and and it's
all the producers it's Wes Craven it's a
lot of the actors and they tell it as it
is they say this is BS this was crap uh
we had to write all this stuff because
the studio wanted to do it Bob Shea had
his hand in this franchise and had to be
like in every single like he makes
cameos in every single one of these
movies just because he really really
wanted to and then and then I think one
of the coolest things is like right
around where nightmare New Nightmare
came out uh they came to Wes Craven they
said they wanted him to make another one
and he's like all right fine let me take
a look at all these movies and I'll see
what I can do and he actually had the
idea for New Nightmare like around the
time I think uh Dream Warriors came out
or it was kind of like floating in his
brain a little bit so after he
re-watched everything he said all right
you know what I I'll do another one but
I'm gonna do it my way and you literally
casts Bob Shea he casts like an
executive producer all the actors Robert
Englund Heather langenkap and everybody
comes back and he just has this play on
on this franchise in Hollywood and
making this movie meta and making Freddy
an actual demon and honestly one of the
scariest versions of Freddy I think
we've ever seen still a couple of his
little quips here and there like you
want to play skin the cat all that
really great stuff but it's just it's
just fascinating I think almost more so
than these movies as much as I love them
the behind the scenes and all the drama
that happened behind all them is just as
fascinating because it just it shows you
how these movies are made and I would
love to see something like like another
like six or eight hour documentary
series on the paranormal movies or the
saw franchise because I'm sure they ran
into those same things where they were
kind of just writing as they were coming
out because they were forced to make
these movies I've never heard a boring
backstory on a classic horror film The
Exorcist clearly has like the curse set
as does Poltergeist The Conjuring like
they built a house to recreate it but
that house still started making people
feel real uncomfortable so it's really
intriguing stuff going all the way back
deep into Wes Craven's history because
the name Freddy Krueger actually came
from Wes's childhood Fred Krueger was
the name of a school bully that used to
tease Wes Craven and so I'd say egotism
oh my God that guy is probably so sick
he is he is big mad on that one yeah but
no one school boys he probably still
wears his varsity jacket and he's
drinking at Chili's at 2PM and he's
trying to tell anybody that will listen
to his name that he's the real Fred
Krueger so if you look at what we
consider to be the greatest nightmare
Elm Street movie of all time like I I
can hear an argument obviously for the
original one I think it's earned its
place 95 certified fresh is very very
high for any horror movie I think it's
earned it just on premise alone and it
sets us up there's a great kill where
Johnny Depp gets sucked into a bed it's
awesome yes but it's wonderful if you
give me if you say Mark what's the best
night when I'm Street movie and I might
say it might be my favorite horror movie
of all time not named The Exorcist
nightmare numbers three three the Dream
Warriors here we go first of all it's
directed by Chuck Russell who would go
on to do the mask and this film is great
because we get Peak Freddy being scary
and also Peak comedy Freddy at the same
time Freddy is in full control of his
Creative Kill Powers he turns one poor
kid into a meat puppet and throws him
off a roof he does another thing where
he he's he takes a girl who's addicted
to watching television because that's
how she'll stay awake she's watching The
Dick Cavett Show and and Dick Cavett
makes a cameo in the movie because he
turns into Freddy Krueger and she gets
stuffed into the TV set and then Freddie
says now you're on prime time it's so
good and the real selling point of this
is twofold for me though is that it's
the return of Heather langenkamp maybe
the best final girl ever with apologies
to Jamie Lee Curtis because she was the
she played Nancy and she's the original
Teen in a neighboring Elm Street that
survives and we think everything's okay
and then she's out everybody's out for
Freddy uh two and then we get back into
her story where she's now a counselor
for troubled teens and she can relate to
them all too well so the teens around
town they're seeing these things they're
having these dreams they're acting weird
send them to this mental institution
she comes in and when there's a Sit
there's a sit around and they're just
having a meeting it's a it's a rap
session and the kids are like look you
adults just do not get it you don't
understand what we're going through and
then Nancy says I know who you're
talking about he wears a dirty Brown hat
it's like oh I still get chills just
talking about it and then you have the
reveal that I think is such a great
reveal for the mythology of a Nightmare
on Elm Street there's this creepy nun
who still haunts my dreams she's wearing
the all-white away game habit it's the
color Rush habit that she'd wear if she
was Thursday night football and she
disappears in the background that she
starts giving advice to the sort of the
head of the institution as far as like
what to do and he just thinks it's like
some you know random old none from the
convent turns out very end of the movie
The Day Numa if you will we've saved the
day we think the world is safe but for
how long Nancy doesn't make it on the
live R.I.P the the head of the
institution is looking for this nun he
sees her from a distance and he runs and
he turns a corner what is find a grave
she's been dead the whole time it's The
Ghost and what's her name you guessed it
Amanda Krueger it was Freddy's freaking
mom it was Freddy's mom the whole time
oh God it's so good am I am I crazy or
does the dream or he's not deserve its
frustrating I'm so happy to see this
yeah no it definitely does and I will
say too just the idea that they had a
movie in that franchise that had that
many fresh entries Halloween would die
for this yeah Halloween would die for
these numbers it really does when you
think about it like I would say where's
Evil Dead Evil Dead both of them were
good right yeah yeah I prefer the second
one but yeah but I would just say like I
just I I really do feel that the whole
franchise average wise but just also
where you look at it like you could
honestly make an argument that it has
two maybe even three top tier entries
depending on the criteria yeah no yeah
and I and I definitely think Dream
Warriors is that one that is like the
definitive as much as I love Freddie too
uh uh Dream Warriors is is the best one
and yeah like Frank Darabont uh helped
write the script and like so you have
people that like actually care about the
franchise
um and I I think like especially with
that movie as much as I love it there's
there's so much like even more potential
that I think they could have done with
it too like this movie walks so
Inception can run this movie is pretty
much Inception if you really really
think like that oh that was a pull and
like I yeah
oh shout out that poor okay okay thank
you thank you I'm sure someone said it
I'm sure somebody said it no I really
love that that's really smart but I uh
yeah I I and there's because there's so
many cool ideas because this is where
the the movies start to become kind of
like the kill of the day where Freddy
they just they they start to come up not
so much with dream Wars because dream
Wars is actually kind of smart but with
the franchise just overall the writer is
just like okay how can we kill people in
dreams and they start doing that and
then they introduce the jokes with with
Freddy but with Dream Warriors in
particular it rides the line so
perfectly of being scary and also a
little campy and fun with Freddie
starting to have those one-liners but
he's doing it in service of tormenting
them not just for the sake of being a
joke and that's what makes that movie so
great and also the same thing with
Amanda Kruger popping in you add in this
sort of like classical uh a ghost story
Into The Mix where like a ghost is like
giving you this information that's
trying to help you with the rest of the
plot and um it all just kind of comes
together so beautifully and you know
they go down the road a hole with the
Mana Kruger eventually in in the in four
and five and it gets a little crazy
um but that one in particular is just so
great also I do love that they killed
Nancy in that movie because and you know
how like Studios could probably still do
this but they can't really do the whole
like Halloween 2018 where they bring
back and they just do a straight sequel
because everybody loves Dream Warriors
and you're not going to ignore Dream
Warriors and Nancy's dead so you can't
bring her back because there's no Dream
Warriors yeah and unless they do like a
straight sequel to New Nightmare which I
think would be interesting and that'd be
probably be the best way to go I was
like Christian
anybody y'all didn't get Christian on
this thing like I mean I'm maybe it's
that I don't think of horror franchises
this way but I've never examined like
which in an entry is the one that you
build from but like that is a like New
Nightmare is also one that I personally
like more than the first one I wouldn't
say it's a better movie I just like it
more there's so much fertile ground
there I think with both Dream Warriors
and and Wes Craven's New Nightmare and
you you can't understate how necessary
Wes Craven's New Nightmare was to the
night right Elm Street franchise because
after we get through Dream Warriors
which was part three the next one that I
really care about despite my Affinity
slash Terror of Amanda Krueger is
Nightmare Elm Street six Freddy's Dead
Oh The Final Nightmare and I love that
movie because that just leans so far
into Freddy doing Thursday night The
Late Show at the Funny Bone and part of
that is like it was the day that school
let out me and my buddies ran to the
movie theater because that was like that
nice period in the mid early 90s where
whoever's working there did not care if
the movie was rated art though I just
get in here we just need the business so
they handed you the the 3D glasses that
movie wasn't 3D and so the claws like
came at you and it was like a pretty
cool theater experience I the movie does
not hold up as well upon re-watching it
but there's also just a cool factoid in
that movie where you are having a dream
and I think one of the counselors in
Freddy's Dead
reveals this is that he's having a dream
of Freddy's in there and then right
before somebody pulls him out of the
dream and he wakes up he grabs Freddie's
sweater and he pulls it and so you can
actually pull stuff from the dream world
into the real world and then that's how
you get him so it's not that well
executed as far as how to get Freddy in
the end but it's it's a cool little
piece of oh we can also do this so maybe
this is how we defeat this guy but after
that movie you watch it and you're like
yeah we got some good laughs now I'm
playing with power there's some funny
lines from Freddy you know that we gotta
entirely reboot this thing or go super
meta which is what Wes Craven ended up
doing yeah yeah I have a question for
you uh Christian just out of curiosity
with dream master do you think if they
do you think it's like a bad idea to do
a sequel off of dream master are you
just saying it's not gonna work as well
because
sorry yeah sorry DreamWorks yeah they
they I mean honestly they could
literally say like oh yeah she survived
you know like yeah like they could they
could do whatever they want and I'm sure
people will go out and see it and
they'll enjoy it then they very much
could do just a straight sequel to the
original Nightmare on Elm Street and
people will be like because you know the
Halloween franchise has rebooted itself
within its franchise and Jamie Lee
Curtis has played Lori Strode as
multiple timelines of herself anyways
even after she's like died so they could
literally do anything but I think like
the the best way to do uh just a
nightmare A New Nightmare on Elm Street
movie is just to like make it a new
entry like make it number seven and then
just start fresh start fresh all new
characters we don't need I'm I'm a
little tired of the the nostalgic and
and bringing back people from the past
and like I think that's great giving
those people work but give me some fresh
faces I think the the new Scream movie
did a great job of of doing such that
they granted they brought back the
original cast but they focused so much
on the new cast and they were great and
so I think and then you also cast a new
Freddy and you start a new franchise
just start a whole new Trilogy I mean
fortunately we tried that and I think
that's it this is just me putting on my
studio exact hat now it's like well we
tried that in 2010 Yeah by just
rebooting a nightmare in Elm Street with
Jackie Earl Haley stepping in to play
the role of Freddy Krueger and I think
that that did actually leave some fans
cold because Robert England was still
available and capable of playing it they
just wanted to go in a different
direction which I understand they had a
big Rising Star Rooney Mara was one of
the teenagers but that movie I don't
think that it deserves to be where as
low as it is on the Tomato Meter it's 14
which is like yeah the audience score is
43 I think a lot of that is due to this
being the first time that maybe a
generation saw Freddy Krueger and and so
it felt more original then but I I I'm
always up for more Freddy Krueger I just
feel like it's maybe just now in 2022
heading into next year now we've left
enough time passed to get that stench
out of the room the one thing I will say
is I think people what they're realizing
now especially with these reboots
rebates whatever this is nothing new
this is the thing I get so irritated
with people when they say that it's like
okay well like literally at the
beginning of Hollywood when you have
movies like Phantom of the Opera and
other things those were all like silent
movies first and then they made them
into Black and Whites then they made
them into colors I'm like Hollywood does
this it's just the timeline of the
reboots and the revamps were longer our
attention spans and distance between
when they decided to do another one of
them was longer and we've just made that
shorter but I don't think it's a bad
idea to keep Reinventing it and I think
scream is a good example Christian but I
would say with Scream what they did
which is I actually think the new
version of the like reboot whatever is
you have to get the audience in on the
joke that's what scream did well and I
think that more than like if you bring
in old people or if you make it
completely new I think the main thing is
is you have to treat the audience like
there's smarts that's what I think
scream did that was different is it
didn't treat the audience like they were
dumb with what they were doing yeah and
and I think they need a director and a
writer who truly love the the property
that they're working on
um radio silence those guys are Huge
Horror fans and they're great their
movies are fantastic and so they
obviously love and it's funny because
it's also Wes Craven so you know there's
also like I think that's another thing
you have to keep in mind too is like out
of respect for him and his work because
he is so vital uh to the horror genre
just in general because he's made not
just one but two even some argue three
of the greatest horror films of all time
and so that's something I think that
also has to be put out there and you
know with the 2010 remake that you know
that guy the guy who directed it it was
like Samuel Bayer buyer he that was his
only film he directed I think he was
like a commercial director so they just
kind of like plucked somebody out to do
that and you know I'm not a fan of that
movie I think there's a lot of stuff
that is very interesting I think Jackie
Earle Haley is actually great in that
role I do too and it's just a lot of
like the stuff that they do with his
origin in that movie is just like uh
because he's always been a child killer
and and not another child predator he's
like that's not fun don't do that that's
just yeah get that get that out of this
one fantasy horror film you know Brian
uh sent me a quick note to remind me of
this
um that he was a music video director
and I don't remember this particularly
but the one thing I liked about Freddy
versus the one thing I liked about
Freddy versus Jason is I felt that it
was style over substance like it was so
like you know whatever this movie didn't
seem like it understood that it wanted
to be that like it almost feels like
this is a movie where I feel a lot of
push and pull between studio and
director like maybe the director wanted
it to be more substantive substance
substantive or substantial substantial
substantial substantial there you go
she's a writer you get the three of us
in a room figure it out yeah we'll
figure it out it was I think he wanted
something more substantial he wanted
something more pushing the envelope and
I think the studio realized very quickly
that they needed this and I think that's
why it feels herky-jerky am I wrong I
think I haven't seen in a long time it's
also it's a Platinum Platinum doomed
movie right I think that's I think
that's Michael Bay's company and that's
during the time when every horror film
was being remade and um so I think it
just it kind of also gets pitted into
all of that which I'll even say it the
Friday the 13th remake I think it's
probably the best Friday the 13th movie
that we've ever had it wasn't bad it's
pretty good yeah yeah and and on
Jacqueline snowed earlier about how like
most horror franchises would kill
literally to have three fresh movies
that are as highly regarded as number in
Elm Street Friday the 13th I think it's
just that first movie where it's not
even Jason showing up yet to kill it's
Jason's mom running around and it's
barely fresh it's like 62 or 63 percent
and so from there it was pretty much all
downhill for Friday the 13th
um if if we look get I I still think
that you could have done a sequel to
that 2010 a nightmare in Elm Street
because it still made some money and you
just don't go the Freddy's Revenge route
you go right into more of the war and
because Freddy wasn't that funny in the
first movie back in 84 there were a
couple barbs that he had but he was
still more menacing than he was
hilarious then it gradually started
enjoying the kills a little too much for
most people's temperament but if we go
to the the real question here when we're
all sitting around at bars talking about
our favorite horror movies for each one
of y'all is there a particular I'll open
it up to either a Freddy kill that he
does it's creative that really got your
goat or just a scare in any of the
nightmare Elm Street movies that really
stand out for me it is in Dream Warriors
and it's sort of a riff off of what we
saw in the first Eminem Street movie
where his head comes through the wall in
Dream Warriors it's like a giant version
of Freddy's coming through the when it
takes up like the whole world has the
really cool look so I love how he
doesn't just kill he has fun with it is
it look I'm not saying that's the hobby
any listeners need to have you probably
shouldn't but whatever you do if you
love it it never feels like a job you
love what you do and you won't work a
day in your life
um uh Christian Jacqueline y'all got
some some Great Kills some great moments
in Nightmare on Street uh War for us I
mean you already said the one Johnny
Depp
um I've watched that kill that's also a
kill that shows up in that video I was
talking about the blood shoots up
everywhere the parents are like what the
hell is
yeah and I think they they honestly cast
Johnny Depp because he was just so
gorgeous like they were like I think the
casting directors were just like oh my
gosh and and then he you know he started
doing his thing in acting in the movie
and they're like oh wow he's such a he's
such a great talent
um I think for me uh I think the
scariest moment for me is in the first
nightmare movie
um when Freddie is walking down the
alley and his arms start stretching out
I think it's just it's such a perfect
blend of like Dreamscape and and realism
because you don't know if she's dreaming
or she's awake and then you start
stretching his arms and doing all these
things and taunting her by scratching
his nails against the wall and just
really really tormenting her really
driving in that fear so that way he can
he can get her I think that's terrifying
for me but my favorite moment in the
entire franchise is from Nightmare 4
which is uh the dream master there's a
moment when the Alice character and um I
don't know if it's her boyfriend but Dan
the character they are on their way to
go rescue a friend and they get stuck in
this time Loop and you don't you don't
they don't they don't notice it they do
it like three times where they get in
their truck they drive off they they
like turn a like turn a corner or
they're about to go into the house and
then they come back out through where
they just started and it just keeps
going and it's such a perfect little
like oh yeah that's a dream and I think
that's that's like a little lightning
and a bottom moment for them especially
because for that movie where they're
just like well what are we gonna do and
then oh we have this dream Loop sequence
that we can do that's really cool and I
just think that's that's perfect like I
want more like really messing with not
just the characters but also mess with
the audience a little bit like make some
weird weird dream like stuff in these
movies because as long as you establish
like what the rules are then you can
start playing with them because if I
have any like gripe with the franchise
it's like establish those rules a little
bit better because they do do that in
the first movie like Mark we were
mentioning about pulling stuff from out
of the dream and that's how you can get
Freddy and pull him into the real world
real world eventually right right
establish show is a little bit better
and then you can start to have your fun
yeah but and I love that a lot of these
kids those two especially the time Loop
one you're talking about it sort of puts
us the audience in that state where we
don't know if we're asleep or awake
anymore and and if you you know if
you're like a [ __ ] in college you're
trying to get in a fraternity it's like
they have like those stunts like try to
stay awake for 36 hours or whatever and
I can't even I can't stay away for five
hours now in my normal day but it it
like kind of puts you in that like
really deep like meditative like I don't
know where I am right now I need to rest
and I'm terrified to do it I think the
perfect mix of everything that we've
seen from Freddy happens in Wes Craven's
New Nightmare and it's when Nancy
realizes exactly what the hell is the
source of all this weird stuff that's
going on with her with her kid with her
life and she's in bed and she opened she
lifts up the coverage and she looks
there then Freddy's head is right there
and he just looks so Sinister and he
just says miss me and because it's it's
Freddy being a little funny but it's not
Freddy telling jokes it's also Freddy
being like this is demon Freddy and he
is coming after you we cannot stop this
conversation here in movie talk until we
also reference
I might be the minority here I feel like
the Freddy's theme
is scarier than either Friday the 13th
or all apologies to The Legend John
Carpenter Halloween because this was the
first one that I remember like my sister
and I staying up late looking in the
bathroom mirror and singing it seeing if
anything comes through the one two
Freddy's coming for you just the piano
that dun dun dun dun dun
it's so good and it still gives me
chills when I hear it today best horror
movie theme Jaclyn Coley is it this or
do you go to the OG another JC John
Carpenter John Carpenter or this
to be Rebels from Exorcist really gets
that's a good one yeah I mean
no I would have to say my favorite
horror franchise if I had to pick a
franchise and y'all are gonna hate me
for it is leprechaun it is it always
will be this girl does not want to get
scared Christian she just she's here for
the laughs she's the best it's the best
it's the best I'm sorry it's the best as
far as what I want out of a horror movie
because my favorite horror movies are
horror comedies to begin with I cannot
think of a movie that just really
terrified and most of the horrors that I
really like the best are like more
horror Thrillers so if you're just
looking for something that I think can
live in at least that we are really
trying to scare you genre
leprechaun there's scary moments of
leprechaun you cannot deny it okay and
and Christian I will say just
piggybacking off your Inception point
which is a lot more high brow than what
I'm about to say you don't get
leprechaun unless you get Freddy first
you don't get that guy running around
cracking jokes unless Freddy pioneered a
decade before uh Chris arubalcaba you
can take the music cue you can take any
other scene any other movie that you
want to uh kind of close up shop here
you have the last word in movie talk for
the nightmare Elm Street franchise oh if
I'm going a nightmare thing I'm doing DJ
uh Jazzy Jeff with the Fresh Prince
theme for the Nightmare and Elm Street
one the nightmare on my street I think
that's the one it's called oh it's a
great little song remember yeah go check
that song out it's a good one um
good one good one on the thing um I uh I
I you know uh as far as like themes go
uh yeah I think the nightmare one is
definitely underrated I think it should
be talked about a lot more because yeah
we do talk about like John Carpenter's
theme especially with him coming back
and doing the new movies I think that
it's him planet is cool yeah I think
there the best thing about those movies
as I haven't seen Halloween ends at the
time of this recording yet uh but the
best thing about those movies is the
score that he's doing with his sons and
it's just brilliant brilliant brilliant
stuff yeah
um but uh yeah no just uh those things
are are really great and um yeah I just
I love this franchise so much I'm glad
they didn't go to space
um maybe maybe leprechaun went to space
first and then it was Jason X I can't
remember if which one came first so
maybe uh we can give some credit to
leprechaun or not we have to fact check
those but uh
um yeah no I love this franchise and I I
want to see more I want to see like a
Mike Flanagan tackle a nightmare
announceary because I think that would
be fair I think that would be perfect
absolutely and I think he's been gunning
for it I think I've seen some tweets
from him where he's like I can take a
stab at this I would I would love to see
that and I think it's been enough time
for us to to do this right have the kid
from stranger things the the guy who
played vechna he pretty much played
Freddy Krueger in in that in that show
so have him okay so interesting all
right yeah Heather wagonkamp one of the
great final girls of all all time
Justice for Kincaid didn't get enough
run killed him off way too early in the
dream master for my taste but uh look we
could gripe all day about the little
issues we have with Nightmare on Elm
Street it's an incredible horror
franchise and I think that Jack and I
agree with Christian rubalcaba it's time
to have this see the light of day once
again let's get more Freddy in our lives
Christopher Rubik I can't believe this
was the first time I've actually had you
as a guest here on Rotten Tomatoes it's
wrong you're fantastic you aced the test
as we knew you would uh thanks for
joining us where can everybody find the
stuff you're working on including some
of these Great Horror shorts that you
put out uh with your company Amateur
hour films it's really good scary stuff
oh thank you uh yeah we do occasional
short films and sketches on YouTube uh
on amateur films just look us up on
YouTube I got a couple up there now we
released a short film last Halloween
that we shot like in a week and then we
just put it up it's called Grandma it's
a lot of fun uh and we actually have a
Halloween fan film that we shot years
ago like almost like six years ago
called the shape go check that one out
that's uh that one's coming up on its
anniversary and uh yeah just working on
a couple of other things right now uh
just uh enjoying spooky month and uh
yeah go check out our podcast the Wenger
show it's a lot of fun you creative
types the wangers is every Monday night
the uh the fellas get together uh
occasionally they're joined by a guest
it's always a good time with a couple
beers being thrown back and so uh as we
say good night here Christian you got a
quick move your TV recommendation for us
uh particularly for this time of year
something that the kids need to have on
the radar I mean I think uh if if we're
talking nightmare on Elm Street go most
of these movies are streaming right now
and on various platforms so I'd go check
them out if you can find the documentary
never sleep again and you can and you
have six or seven hours of your time uh
go and and check that out because it is
fantastic especially if you love these
movies uh and I'll even throw in the the
Friday the 13th one because there's also
like a 10 hour documentary on all the
Friday the 13th movies in the same style
as never sleep again go watch those
those are a lot of fun great Jaws
documentary behind the scenes on The
Exorcist on shutter a lot of good stuff
for horror fans to get below skin deep
but you can email us anytime RT is
running around tomatoes.com subscribe
rate review to this podcast whatever
your preferred platform asks you to do
do it for us because you just care that
much about your friends here at Rotten
Tomatoes this wrong that is Jacqueline
Coley wonderful to have you back and uh
and looking better than ever covering
stuff all over the world thank you for
joining us talking about some subject
matter that you know not always the best
for you but I enjoyed our time together
for me I enjoyed our time together sir
don't take it for like that I didn't I
enjoyed our time next week we're keeping
the Creeps in the scares and we're
taking it outer space because we're
talking out of Renton Horizon that's
going to be a really fun one we need to
talk about every scene with Mr fish with
Mr Fish Mr Fishburne who was in
Nightmare on Elm Street three there we
go and uh that's gonna do it for us here
today thank you all so much for joining
us at Rotten Tomatoes is wrong for the
whole gang here I am Mark Ellis we'll
see you next week and in the meantime to
quote Freddy Krueger you have the body I
have the brain
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]